when I saw the Oliver Stone was
directing a movie about Edward Snowden I
was intrigued not just because it's a
topic that interests me but because it's
a subject that that was covered by one
of the best documentaries made in the
last several years Citizen for the
documentary was released just two years
before Oliver Stone's movie Snowden it's
not just a documentary about Edward
Snowden it's a documentary that's tied
directly to his story and his actions
Laura Poitras the creator of the
documentary was one of the journalists
that's known first contacted to get the
leak underway because of this I was
curious to see how the movie would
approach the scenes featured in the
documentary we know movies based on true
events are dramatized but rarely are we
given such a clear comparison which we
can use to see how things are dramatized
Oliver Stone's movie seems like an
attempt to present the story of Edward
Snowden in a way that's more palatable
to the general audience while citizen
for sought to create context for its
core events it remains somewhat
inaccessible to those without at least a
little understanding of its context
Stone presents a modified version of
reality events are changed usually
mildly they on the alligator we will
need in the hallway outside of the
restaurant in the narrow hotel I will be
working on a loop excuse so you can
identify me
what time is the restaurant open
approached me and asked if I know the
hours of the restaurant well respond by
stating that I'm not sure and suggest
you try the lounge instead man it's
physically disrespect I'll offer to show
you where and at that point was good
he's continued with long naturally he
pulls ingredients and ideas from the
documentary footage
sometimes replicating specific moments
can you start by telling us why you did
what you did and how you came to access
to such a customer's information all of
which I've read on the plane I basically
woke up this mine already started
writing stories so I'm hoping to you
know start publishing with them like a
day or two days okay as long as you're
good with that yeah and and then other
moments are more dramatized so I don't
know who you are or and the thing about
you okay I work for Booz Allen Hamilton
before we go onto the stories I need to
know Mona barking your career by a
glance account is very varied but the
god game needs evidence defense
contractor on that sort of on loan to
NSA my diplomatic passport for friendly
countries my tourist task force for
everywhere else you can check that visa
stamps in my NSA badge would threw down
my CIA guys would tell and this is my
dia instructors batch so I don't know
your name
oh hi hi my name is Edward Snowden I go
by Eddie and some are the opposite of
reality we seriously have to think about
doing this on our own websites we have
no choice
well you can't just stop dumping
articles on the internet Glenn be
serious look at WikiLeaks they destroyed
that credibility then the Guardian is
WikiLeaks painful people set up a system
so that were available for anybody to
see and just wonder if it's possible to
do the same thing that that would be the
ideal and gain but because because some
of these documents
or legitimate including classified and a
scene that sticks out to me particularly
is one where stone chooses to show some
shots from the point of view of the
fictional lares camera these shots are
color graded to look more like camcorder
footage and are shot with a more
observational handheld camera style that
has come to be somewhat of a stylistic
shorthand for what a documentary should
look like the irony here is that in real
life only a little of Laura's footage
looks anything like this there are
moments of shaky handheld footage in
citizen 4 but they're relatively short
and constrained and majority of the
footage in the documentary is fairly
steady her documentary actually appears
fairly cinematic by some standards stone
uses shaky handheld footage to indicate
to the audience
this is documentary footage Laura uses
study well framed and lit shots to give
her documentary a more cinematic and
dramatic feeling the lines between the
narrative form and the documentary form
are blurred the exteriors of Hong Kong
serve as excellent transitions in both
the movie and the documentary and both
use news programs as a means of
exposition there are companies receiving
Microsoft Yahoo Google Facebook AOL
Skype YouTube and Apple with reality TV
YouTube blogs mockumentaries and
historical dramas the lines between
documentary and fiction have become
increasingly blurry while I think Oliver
Stone is mostly responsible in his
fictionalization of this story as
viewers we need to be smart and
discerning fiction can look like reality
an increasingly reality can look like
fiction we can't simply judge the
authenticity of something in a film by
whether it feels genuine and true to us
as the viewer even when they're mostly
factually accurate like stones movie
adaptations from true stories are still
fiction
many contemporary dramas are attempting
to inform us in engaging ways and
documentaries are becoming more dramatic
and enticing as audiences we need to
view both was a critical eye
yes no I don't okay thank you asking
from one turndown service that do not
serve sounds off the door hello yes now
my meal was great thank you very much
yes I'm Thomas flight this has been
another video for off the screen if you
enjoyed this video please consider
sharing it and hit the subscribe button
to see a new video each